Kilis it's your [ __ ] tariff yeah yeah
alien something yeah it's the one like
alien the original movie yeah yeah
you're on a ship it's a it starts with
the doors open up and that little thing
drink them of the water that little
tchotchke on the yeah on the desk and
it's a yeah it really gives a good
recreation of the movie which was
[ __ ] awesome that's wonderful goes
down is one of my favorites he's also
one of my favorite examples when people
talk about pushing diversity in movies
oh yeah this movie had a female lead
who's a female superstar who spoiler
alert once up winning in the end time
yeah but you don't even notice now it
never feels like it's crammed down your
throat right is the last Star Wars yeah
it was like get the [ __ ] out of here
Laura Dern you're not running the Empire
like what is this like she's the head
general and then carrie fisher's the
other head general and they're telling
these men to shut up and this all makes
sense to you
isn't that [ __ ] amazing mistress dude
they had it that was 1979 and they had
more of an idea of how to present that
then yeah first of all Sigourney Weaver
is just a [ __ ] badass badass
believable movies believe that she pull
it together she was such a great actress
yeah so that's alien the descent this
was like that thing that you did at
Disney though Oh to go to free-roaming
VR California exactly well that that
would Jamie know talked about that many
times like that's the future like a
warehouse like this space out here but
converted into giant VR experience yeah
yeah Jamie orange California we need to
go yeah when I first saw alien back you
know kids I saw it in the movie theater
when I first came out there kids my mom
took me it was 79 yeah yeah it was
believe it was just one of those movies
that at the time everyone goes oh my god
you got to see this that the chest
[ __ ] burst a scene just slayed people
but yeah when you're watching that
because traditional movies the guys the
hero and yes
what happens when tom skerritt gets it
you're just like wait what yeah they
just killed the the star the hero that
was it was tom skerritt yeah as i not
his [ __ ] movie a big movie star yeah
yeah and then i think it was like with
the first movie where where the
spaceship was kind of a truck and it was
just dirty and you know just regular
guys concerned about getting paid and
and [ __ ] like that so uh yeah that's why
it was amazing which is this one this is
a covenant in utero
oh so this is after the covenant movie
which is a [ __ ] awesome one that's
yeah i like that me someone I love yeah
damn movies I'd love a good good I like
that [ __ ] that movie they nailed it it
was just great
it didn't matter for woman was running
and it was right they weren't shoving it
down your throat
no as I felt like that last Star Wars
one with Laura Dern and Carrie Fisher
was like flying flying Carrie Fisher
come on
yeah I stopped I wasn't feeling it I
didn't feel like they were look there's
certain women like what is her name from
house of cards the head woman uh yeah
what's in Jenny from Jenny from [ __ ] oh
yeah Penn so it's something something
something Penn [ __ ] her name I think
she used that so good - I'm Robyn Robyn
right yeah Robyn right okay Robin Wright
was playing in general I believe it yes
I mean [ __ ] right she she could send in
some [ __ ] tanks yeah leave I believe
that she would like Nuka planet I'd buy
that right Carrie Fisher and Lauren her
and I was like c'mon I see what you're
doing here
they're running things I I think they've
they just they're putting out too many
Star Wars movies to have it that
mystique and that kind of atmosphere
that it was like to go to one of them
years ago it's also it's it's Disney now
yeah yeah which is great cuz you're it's
consistent and it's good right but it's
never stunning it's not terrifying
it's never it's never ex machina right
right yeah yeah it's never [ __ ] up
like will you leave the theater going
holy [ __ ]
yeah yeah can't do that anymore they
know I'm gonna polish off the sharp
edges and soothe the experience down
right palatable mainstream appeal yeah
that first the first Star Wars back in
77 again I saw that in a movie theater
with my uncle my Uncle Joe took me and I
didn't know Star Wars from a hole in the
wall I remember the trailer playing on
TV and I was like that seems kind of
cool and then we sit down and that
opening scene with the giant ship just
doesn't fly over and I was just from
that point on I was just mesmerizing
this the The Illusionist sighs that they
got in the ship and [ __ ] the idea of
like plastic model car yeah practical
effects it was small like models like
they went and bought like a bunch of
different you remember those old models
that we used to do at cars and oh yeah
thank them yeah remember those I glue
them together you get the model glue
right I still love those yeah they took
a bunch of parts from those things and
built the Millennium Falcon they built
those battleships from like parts like
you can kind of tell cuz they're so
weird and eclectic and some of the parts
don't seem to match right worked yeah it
totally worked
yeah that was you know if you you didn't
imagine being in one of those x-wing
fighters as a kid it was just an amazing
thing it's yeah that's kind of gone it
shows you how great alien like Ridley
Scott's alien really was because all
those Star Wars was a great movie
honestly Star Wars doesn't really hold
up mm-hmm I give you watch it today you
look at the special effects like what
what am I watching this yeah so clunky
and and then the Catena scene yeah yeah
that's always mouths don't move like the
monster face like yeah
it's weird if they're wearing a mask
it's really obvious but then you go just
two years later to Ridley Scott's alien
that [ __ ] holds up today